oMG was all of our reactions when we saw
the list of famous guest stars that have
joined be friends guest star club an
indelible moment in my life and I'm his
friend dr. Rosen aren't you a little
cute to be dr. it was the first sitcom I
ever did and I remember getting a laugh
about hummus or chickpeas or something
and thinking this is so stupid I'm
getting a laugh on this line god bless a
chickpea the person who I had all my
scenes with who was just being here with
all of you in event room see him in real
life that's when you play the puzzle -
Carson right I'm sorry that's who I am
I'm a positive person people remember me
Gabrielle Union and I used to Tyler I
don't know what other black people are
on there boyfriend no I'm Joey you know
you're the first black where's my friend
and then someone somewhere at the
network was like no we counted and
you're actually the first
african-american love interest on
friends
I'm sorry have I made this evening
uncomfortable some people still like oh
my kid is watching that show now and
they love you on that show and I'm like
I look the same don't I was on that show
don't learn the words what the words
learn you couldn't just sleep with the
producer
everyone from the Duchess of York to a
real housewife has made an appearance
191 guest stars in all including a
couple of Jennifer's exes she was
breaking up with n boyfriend take
Donovan when he played her love interest
on the show sometimes we'd slip in the
goal hold a second you guys don't know
each other might write but
eight-year-old Cole Sprouse is the one
who had a crush on her I remember being
infatuated with Jennifer Aniston now
what is my first line yes she does
and beautiful eyes my wife understand
Tom Selleck shaved his stache when he
did his 10 episode arc on the show oh
that cast was family everybody was
sitting on everybody's lap Courtney on
somebody's lap and Bruce Willis won an
Emmy for the role he agreed to do after
losing a bet to Matthew remember they
starred in the whole nine yards together
hi Ross
you can't spell friends without Hannigan
no one else has a name like that
we never quite could get over the fact
that I was sitting in Central Perk what
was your best memory about working on I
can't believe I'm here Tara I don't know
is that a good memory
[Music]